en tant que vice-président de
l'assemblée nationale on a chacun une
délégation et ma délégation concerne les
représentants d'intérêts c'est le mot
poli pour dire les lobbys et des lobbys
pouvant être à la fois des associations
qui portent des causes ou à la fois des
entreprises qui porte leurs intérêts
économiques
donc dans le cadre de cette délégation
j'ai organisé une approche un peu
particulière pour produire un rapport
avec des propositions en matière de
gestion des lobbys et des relations avec
les lobbys on a vécu assez longtemps
avec l'idée selon laquelle il fallait
construire une espèce de mur de berlin
autour du député pour que sa décision
soit vierge de toute influence et que
personne n'a un flux sur sa décision ce
modèle est évidemment peut-être un peu
hypocrite mais en tout cas hors de
propos aujourd'hui dans cette logique et
dans ce monde de co-construction on
associe les différents intérêts
particuliers la question c'est comment
on y trouve l'intérêt général
il faut déjà voir que la loi confiance
qui a été piloté en début de mandat et
l'évolution du règlement intérieur qui
datent de l'été dernier dont j'étais le
rapporteur un texte à l'initiative du
président ferrand ces deux textes là
doivent maintenant se traduire dans une
réalité d'obligation pour les
représentants d'intérêts et là on parle
d'obligations donne un exemple tout
simple les députés aujourd'hui ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant ont une
obligation déclarative pour tous cadeaux
ou d'invitations plus de 150 euros
et puis on a là proches politiques on à
la pratique politique et là on arrive
sur une thématique que le président
mignola et président legendre ont porté
à mme sur ma proposition qui est le
sourcing des amendements alors c'est
quoi le sourcing des amendements
sourcing des amendements c'est l'idée de
dire d'où vient l'amendement et qu'on
n'est pas des situations où des
amendements puisse être écrit par un
lobby porté par un député sans qu'on le
sache
il ya une question d'honnêteté
intellectuelle dans l'idée de dire je
porte un amendement j'ai rencontré les
apiculteurs français ils sont gravement
impacté par le fait que l'étiquetage des
miels n'indique pas la composition
détaillée du miel et que donc qu'on peut
vous dire me l ua et l'onu a est en fait
il ya 70% de 1000 chinois et donc ça tue
la filière française et donc ils portent
leur intérêt économique c'est du lobby
pur ils viennent voir un député présent
passer un amendement sur le sujet il ya
aucun problème
que le député soit convaincu s'en empare
et près de l'amendement sauf que à mon
sens il doit le faire en transparence en
indiquant d'une phrase que cet
amendement provient de la filière
apicole française alors au parlement
européen effectivement il ya quelques
bonnes pratiques dont s'inspire le
rapport notamment sur l'obligation de
transparence des agendas pour les
rapporteurs de texte c'est un élément
qui aujourd'hui ne peut pas être
généralisée à tous les députés mais pour
un rapporteur on peut rentrer dans cette
logique d'obligations déclaratives à
chaque fois qu'on rencontre un
représentants d'intérêts sur le thème de
la loi contre est pense que tout ce qui
va améliorer la transparence tout ce qui
va mettre les sujets sur la table donc
de laisser caché va participer de cette
reconstruction d'un lien de confiance